foreign
[Music]
accused in the deadly Memphis shooting
attacks this week was in court Friday
Ezekiel Kelly was granted a public
defender after telling a judge he could
not afford a lawyer the 19 year old is
charged with first-degree murder he's
accused of carrying out a rampage that
left four people dead and caused the
city to lock down for hours it comes as
Memphis is still reeling from the murder
of Eliza Fletcher the teacher and mother
of two was abducted and killed last
Friday while out on an early morning jog
a week later a community of Runners came
together all across the country to pay
tribute to her at least Preston is here
with the story Elise good morning Jeff
good morning to you Tennessee's Governor
took to the microphone Friday to assure
the nation that Memphis indeed the state
is a safe place and pledge to make it
safer
defiant joggers throughout the country
ran in solidarity yesterday posting on
social media let's finish Liza's run
spreading the message women should not
be targeted while running it's supposed
to be a safe activity that we all find
solace in it shouldn't be dangerous like
that running while female shouldn't be a
death sentence but that is what happened
to 34 year old Eliza Fletcher a
kindergarten teacher an avid Memphis
Tennessee Runner who last week
disappeared during her routine 4 30 a.m
jog it's heart-wrenching to me and it
hit home because it's so that story her
story is so familiar there's so many
women Runners who are exactly like her
investigators search for the mother of
two for four days before discovering her
body in an abandoned house the
senselessness of Eliza Fletcher's death
rocked Memphis and has rippled far
beyond I know the people of Memphis
yesterday Republican Governor Bill Lee
Coming Out Swinging to get tough on
crime he pointed to the Public's
response as one of Hope thousands of
people in Memphis and across the country
finished Alaska's run
that is the Spirit of Hope
of this city of Memphis court records
show 38-year-old cleotha abston Eliza
Fletcher's alleged kidnapper and killer
had served nearly two decades in prison
for kidnapping a prominent Memphis
attorney when he was 16 years old did
the system fail in in this situation I
don't know all the details on it but it
looked that way very much so the Shelby
County district attorney noted abstin
was released in 2020 after serving 85
percent of his sentence I think what we
just need to do right now is just focus
on going forward and making sure the
justice is done in this particular case
now we still don't know exactly how the
mother of two is killed abstin remains
in jail without bond this morning he's
also facing additional charges in
connection to an unrelated 2021
aggravated rape and kidnapping case Jeff
all right Elise thanks